le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
en équipements hospitaliers de niveaux
européens capable de traiter la plupart
des maladies mais parfois lorsqu'il
s'agit de cas plus complexe les malades
doivent aller en métropole pour
bénéficier de soins mieux adaptés les
prix des billets d'avion sont assez
onéreux alors accompagné un membre de sa
famille pour le soutenir dans cette
épreuve devient compliqué laissez partir
seul à un parent un enfant dans un
moment pareil n'est pas concevable pour
les proches alors comment assumer ses
frais de voyage en tant qu'accompagnant
avec des revenus modestes qui peut
apporter son soutien dans ces moments
difficiles on en parle maintenant dans
lien social
il y a un peu plus d'un an une des
filles de Madame Techer est tombée
malade pour faire face à cette maladie
la jeune fille n'avait d'autre choix que
de se faire hospitaliser en métropole la
sécurité sociale a pris en charge
l'intégralité du voyage car il
s'agissait d'un transport sanitaire
madame teecher a bien sûr souhaité
accompagner sa fille dans ce moment
délicat mais le billet des accompagnants
n'est pas toujours pris en charge par la
Sécurité Sociale et avec des revenus
modestes madame Techer et son mari ne
pouvait pas assumer seul les frais de
déplacement et d'hébergement alors
madame Techer s'est renseigné elle a
appris qu'elle pouvait obtenir de l'aide
auprès du Conseil Général en tant
qu'accompagnant elle s'est adressée à un
bureau du conseil général ou à la montée
un dossier le dossier une fois complet
lui a permis une prise en charge de son
billet d'avion son hébergement et
d'autres aides avant le départ pour la
métropole cette bonne nouvelle a rassuré
madame Techer mais aussi sa fille car
voyager seul à son âge pour des raisons
médicales peut être psychologiquement
déstabilisant arriver à Paris madame
Techer et sa fille ont été accueillies
par le Conseil Général leur offrant
ainsi à soutien et un suivi pendant leur
séjour
sur Paris et le Conseil Général et
personnel d'une personne était là pour
se tenir pour m'aider à traverser cette
épreuve qui était très difficile son
hospitalisation a été plus longue queue
par rapport à la subit deux opérations
donc j'ai fait plus de 1 mois et demi
sur Paris avec ma fille
et je recommanderais bien à tout le
monde à tous les pas les mamans les
familles qui traversent des moments
difficiles comme nous quand on a un
enfant malade et qu'il faut traverser
partir en métropole pour les faire
soigner le Conseil général est là sur
Paris même à la Réunion pour nous aider
pour nous soutenir
n'hésitez pas prenez contact et vous
aurez l'aide vous aurez besoin et le
soutien moi je remercie
très fort conseil général qui m'a
beaucoup aidé
grâce à l'aide du Conseil Général madame
Techer a pu accompagner sa fille hors du
département elle a pu rester auprès
d'elle pour l'aider à faire face à la
maladie madame Techer a pu bénéficier
d'un pack d'accueil qui lui a permis dès
son arrivée à Paris d'avoir des repères
ce pack comprend un téléphone portable
prête à téléphoner des titres de
transport urbains un plan des transports
en commun un plan de la ville les
coordonnées de l'antenne de Paris et le
livret de la compagnon tout ce qui est
nécessaire lorsqu'on est dans une région
on ne connaît pas ou peu il y a plus de
800 réunionnais qui doivent prendre
l'avion pour aller se faire soigner en
métropole et il s'agit d'un enfant ou
d'un adulte et le Conseil général nous
accompagnons ces personnes malades nous
prenons en charge le billet d'avion d'un
autre accompagnant en plus de l'aide de
la sécurité sociale et nous faisons en
sorte qu'elle est les meilleures
conditions dans cette période
douloureuse qu'elle vit alors cette
personne peut bénéficier quel que soit
les conditions de ressources d'impact
qui lui donne un téléphone des tickets
de bus mais également un numéro avec une
personne accompagnante de l'antenne du
conseil général à Paris donc pour toutes
les personnes qui prennent l'avion et
puis si les conditions de ressources ne
sont pas bonnes et ben nous aidons
également la prise en charge du billet
d'avion mais aussi la prise en charge
des frais d'hôtel de la restauration je
crois que les Réunionnais malade avait
besoin de cet accompagnement et pour
cette première année plus de 230
personnes ont été accompagnées par le
Conseil Général
cette aide mise en place depuis un an a
connu un réel succès de nombreuses
familles réunionnaises ont pu en
bénéficier ce dispositif apporte bien
sûr une aide financière mais c'est bien
plus que de l'argent qu'offre le conseil
général en donnant la possibilité aux
malades d'avoir un proche avec eux
pendant une phase difficile de leur vie
le département apporte un soutien moral
et psychologique aux familles
réunionnaises
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais